bon mes chers collègues je pense que
tout le monde a réussi à voter il est
17h on avait tous un peu d'avance mais
on va essayer de commencer à l'heure
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes chers
collègues on laisser Claude
s'installer Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
d'abord merci je vous remerci d'avoir
accepté dans ces heures difficiles
l'invitation de notre commission à nous
éclairer sur les attaques d'une cruauté
abjecte qui endeuille Israël et provoque
évidemment en France douleur et
sidération j'ai adressé mes condoléances
à mon homologogue de la cissette ainsi
qu'à son président et je vous les
présente aujourd'hui à nouveau au nom de
notre commission tout
entière dans un passé récent nous avons
vécu des scènes semblables de terreur
d'horreur nous avons découvert avec
effroi que la cruauté et l'ignominie
pouvaient faire effraction au cœur même
de nos démocraties et nous nous
associons pleinement à votre peine elle
est aussi la nôtre
rien ne justifie la barbarie du Hamas
rien ne justifie
l'antisémitisme et rien ne justifie le
terrorisme nous avons la douleur en
partage mais aussi l'angoisse des
familles françaises sont toujours sans
nouvelle de leurs proches qui sont très
probablement au nombre des 200 à 250
otages détenus par leur hamass nous
souhaitons vous entendre sur plusieurs
points Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous le
savez notre commission est compétente
tant pour les questions internationales
que pour les questions de défense
et nous nous demandons en premier lieu
comment expliquer que le Hamas ait pu
préparer une opération d'une telle
ampleur sans que les services de
sécurité israéliens ne s'en aperçoivent
ou peut-être sans qu'il soit entendu ce
sera à vous de nous le dire une telle
opération nécessite également un soutien
financier et et logistique externe
l'Iran a-t-il été selon vous associé à
la préparation de cette attaque faut-il
y voir comme l'ont suggéré certains
observateurs une opération visant à
torpill le rapprochement entre en cours
entre Israël et l'Arabie Saoudite
ensuite Israël est en train d'organiser
saripost après des bombardements massifs
sur la bande de Gaza il a été demandé à
la population d'évacuer la partie nord
on s'attend à une opération terrestre de
grande ampleur quelles sont les options
militaire qui s'offr à Israël et quel
serait les but d'une telle opération si
l'objectif est d'éradiquer le Hamas en
tant qu'acteur politique et militaire en
éliminant ses dirigeants et une partie
de ses combattants comment y parvenir
sans causer d'innombrables victimes
civiles dans la population de Gaza il y
a en outre l'immense difficulté posée
par les otages parmi lesquels figurent
des Français miashem franco-israélienne
de 21 ans est apparue dans une vidéo
diffusée hier par l'organisation
terroriste et on a appris aujourd'hui
que nous déplourons déjà 21 morts et 11
disparus à ce jour je voudrais formuler
ici mes chers collègues un bref
commentaire personnel euh à l'horreur à
l'horreur du attaque du Hamas faite de
meurtrre d'enfants parfois encore bébés
s'ajoute ce CR crime de la prise en
otage ce mode opératoire confirme que le
Hamas ne différ en rien de daesh comme
français nous avons vu des terroristes
mitrailler notre jeunesse au Bataclan
comment ne pas ressentir la même douleur
et la même révolte en voyant des
terroristes mitrailler la jeunesse
d'Israël dans une fête dans les maisons
dans les berceaux ou encore hier soir
ces images que nous avons tous vu de
supporterir suédois assassinés
mitraillés en pleine rue j'en reviens à
la situation sur le terrain car comme
les élus comme élus nous ne devons pas
perdre de vue la dimension terriblement
concrète de cette tragédie Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur nous pensons que le risque
d'un embrasement général de la région
est réel les escarmouches ont commencé à
la frontière nord et le hzbola soutenu
par l'Iran a annoncé des représailles
massive si l'armée israélienne pénétrait
dans la bande de Gaza Israël serait-elle
serait-il prêt à assumer un affrontement
direct ou indirect avec l'Iran et enfin
si l'idée d'une paix paraît plus loin
que jamais dans ces heures sombres ne
ren nonçons jamais à l'espérer Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur votre Hyne national
s'intitule atikva l'espoir et je crois
que c'est honoré la mémoire des
fondateur de l'État d'Israël et de tous
ceux qui en France depuis 1948 ont
soutenu le droit des Israéliens à vivre
en paix sur la terre d'Israël que de
garder l'espoir qu'un jour la paix
puisse advevenir au Proche Orient la
France a constamment réaffirmé son
attachement à la solution à de deux
états et elle nous semble la seule voie
pour parvenir à une coexistence
pacifique entre israélien et
Palestiniens et c'est pourquoi nous
observons avec préoccupation les
préparatifs en cours nous reconnaissons
bien sûr le plein droit d'Israël à
riposté pour ceux de nos compatriotes
qui suivent cette audition je rappelle
que le nombre de morts tué par le Hamas
équivaudrait à l'échelle de la France à
plus de 10000 morts et si nous Français
voyons 10000 de nos compatriotes être
massacrés dans ces conditions inhumaines
ne serions-nous pas tentés par
l'ariposte la plus ferme Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur nous comprenons la
nécessité militaire pour Israël de
détruire le hamasse comme responsable
politique comme ami d'Israël notre
devoir est de vous demander comment que
se passera-t-il ensuite si tsal entre
dans Gaza nous savons que le ramas ne
reculera devant aucune lâcheté et se
servira de la population de Gaza comme
bouclier humain comment Israël va-t-il
éviter de tomber dans le piège que le
que tend le Hamas et tous ceux qui le
soutiennent ce piège de la communication
et de la radicalisation il souhaite
enfin de compte un affrontement global
entre le monde arabe et Israël voire
évidemment entre le monde arabe et les
pays occidentaux après votre propos
liminaire Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
donnerai la parole à mes collègues pour
des échanges de questions et de réponses
et je vous rappelle à toutes et à tous
que cette audition est captée et
diffusée sur la site le site internet du
Sénat Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je vous
laisse la
parole merci et Monsieur Cédric Perin
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées du Sénat mesdames les sénatrices
et messieurs les sénateurs merci pour V
votre invitation à cette importante
réunion je saisis cette occasion pour
vous remercier de votre soutien de votre
solidarité que vous aveit témoigné suite
à l'attaque terroriste la plus tragique
de l'histoire d'Israël par EMP pleur de
sa barbarie et son bilan humain aussi
Israël a été très sensible à l'hommage
fort que le président du Sénat monsieur
Gérard Larché a rendu en séance publique
mercredi dernier aux victimes
israéliennes mesdames messieurs alors
qu'Israël a progressivement repris le
contrôle et sécuriser les zones
frontalières avec la bande de Gaza que
les terroristes avaient infiltré
l'ampleur du massacre perpétré par le
Hamas a été révélé il s'agit d'une
attaque meurtrière et barbare rappelant
le modus operandi de l'État islamique
initié par des organisations terroristes
dirigées par le Hamas une attaque lancée
sans aucun prétexte légitime ni action
provocative préalable de la part
d'Israël
cette attaque révèle une fois de plus le
vrai visage de ces organisations
terroristes à savoir des groupes
sanguinaire et incontrôlable issu de la
même branche que l'État islamique
dépourvu de toute inhibition morale
motivé par la haine et le désir de
blesser les citoyens israéliens par tous
les moyens et provoquer la destruction
de l'État
d'Israël il est à rappeler que le Hamas
ne se préoccupe pas de la sécurité ou du
bien-être de sa population civile dans
la bande de Gaza il ne les considère que
comme des pions à exploiter dans ses
efforts pour nuire aux citoyens
israéliens à ce jour nous pleurons plus
de 1400 civils assassinés parmi lesquels
des bébés des enfants des femmes et des
personnes âgées et même des rescapés de
la choix les plans du Hamas retrouvé sur
les corps des terroristes prouve que le
Hamas avait parfaitement planifié la
mort et la prise d'otage de civils en
ciblant intentionnellement les femmes et
les
enfants des familles entières ont été
déciimés dans leur maison environ 260
jeunes ont été abattus lors d'un
festival de musique au moins 3500
personnes ont été blessés et beaucoup
ail encore entre la vie et la mort on
décompte 199 personnes kidnappé vers
Gaza de 43 nationalités différentes sans
que l'on connaisse leur sort
alors que le bilan des victimes
françaises tué durant les attaques
meurtrriers du Hamas s'alourd avec 21
morts et 11 disparus selon le qu d'orset
je tiens à présenter nos plus sincères
condoléances aux familles françaises
deuillé et exprimer toute notre
compassion aux familles des otages
français dans ce moment
tragique plus de 6600 roquetes et
missiles ont été tirées à ce jour et
Contin continuent à nous de nous
attaquer sans distinction sur notre
population cont tenu de ces
circonstances Israël est en guerre
contre les organisations terroristes de
la bande de Gaza le Hamas qui exercit
son pouvoir dans la BAT de Gaza où il
contrôle tous les aspects de la vie
depuis 16 ans est à l'origine de cette
attaque et sera tenu pour responsable
des conséquences de ces attaques les
dirigeants du Hamas portent l'entière
charge de la dété
détériorisation actuelle de la situation
et des mesures qu'Israël doit prendre
pour répondre Israël fera tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour protéger ses
citoyens et son territoire à savoir
faire tomber le Hamas détruire ses
infrastructures militaires et éliminer
la menace terroriste que la bande de
Gaza fait peser sur ses
citoyens en même temps Israël déploiera
tous les efforts possibles pour protéger
ses otages ses frontières et ses
citoyens alors on parle beaucoup de la
situation humanitaire ces derniers jours
n'oublions pas que suite aux attaques
terroristes et au tir de roquettes qui
sont toujours en train de s'abattre sur
Israël des dizaines de milliers
d'Israéliens ont été déplacés de leur
maison dans les localités entourant la
bande de Gaza et dispersés dans 10 dans
divers ais abris à travers le pays en
outre en raison des attaques continues
du hezbola sur la frontière nord et du
risque aigu d'escalade qu'elle
représente des milliers de résidents des
localités de la frontière nord ont été
déplacés et de nombreux autres viennent
s'y ajouter chaque jour et n'oublions
pas que le tir des missiles et roquettes
sur la population israélienne continuent
pendant que je vous
parle comme vous le savez bien les
organisations terroristes opère siement
et délibérément à partir de zones
peuplées de civiles et à proximité de
bâtiments et d'institutions humanitaires
qu'elle
instrumentalise néanmoins l'armée
israélienne prend toutes les mesures
possibles conformément au droit
international pour éviter des pertes
civiles ces mesures comprennent
l'avertissement préalable lorsque cela
est possible des actions menées par
l'armée contre le Hamas qui pourraient
causer des dommages à des personnes non
appliquées en conséquence les forces de
défense israéliennes ont averti les
habitants de la bande de Gaza et l'ont
demandé de se rendre dans la zone située
au sud de la ville de Gaza pour les
protéger et les épargner de tout danger
ces avertissements ont été diffusés en
langue arabe par divers canaux
médiatique notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux ainsi que par l'intermédiaire de
la société civile et des organisations
internationales cependant le Hamas s'est
adressé aux habitants de Gaza qu'il
gouverne pour leur interdire d'évacuer
surtout il a appelé les habitants à ce
qu'ils appellent se fondre dans la
Résistance en agissant de la sorte le
Hamas peut continuer à instrumentaliser
les Gazaouis comme bouclier humain pour
ses activités meurtrières en outre de
plus en plus plus de témoignage indique
que le Hamas entrave voire empêche par
la force le déplacement de la population
civile vers la partie sud de la bande de
Gaza
bref tandis que
Israël fait tout le nécessaire pour
protéger sa population le Hamas fait
tout pour éviter la protection de sa
propre population et terroriser les
civils en Israël il est le seul
responsable de cette
situation je rappellerai aussi que le
Hamas détient au moins 199 otages dans
de très mauvaises conditions
humanitaires sans aucun respect du droit
international qui d'ailleurs interdit la
prise d'otage civil dans un conflit armé
israël considère le Hamas comme
entièrement responsable de leur suivi et
de leur bon
traitement vous m'avez posé question sur
euh l'embrasement et
euh sur la sur la frontière Nord alors
dans les jours qui viennent de s'écouler
des missiles antichars et des obus de
mortriers ont été tirés depuis le
territoire libanais sous les auspices du
Hezbollah sur les positions de l'armée
de défense israélienne et ce alors que
des terroristes ont continué de tenter
de s'infiltrer en Israël les forces de
défense israéliennes ont réosté en
ciblant les sources des tirs et en
contrecarant l'infiltration des
terroristes ces derniers jour le
ministre israélien des Affaires
étrangères
ohen a accueilli en Israël plusieurs
ministres des Affaires étrangères venus
témoigner leur solidarité dont la
ministre française des Affaires
étrangères Madame Catherine Colona la
visite en Israël du président des
États-Unis est attendue
demain pour votre question sur l'Iran
les organisations terroristes impliquées
sont des branches du régime d'ayatoll en
Iran qui encourage de manière proactive
les activités terroristes en Israël et
contre des cibles israéliennes et juive
dans le monde entier le Hamas n'aurait
pas été en mesure de mener cette attaque
meurtrière sans le financement le
soutien logistique et les armes qu'il a
reçu de l'Iran de l'Iran la République
islamique d'Iran porte la responsabilité
directe des capacités du Hamas et par
conséquent la responsabilité de de
l'utilisation que le Hamas a fait de ses
moyens il va de soi également pour le
Hizbollah qui constitue le bras long du
régime iranien au Liban qui a annoncé
être responsable de plus que 10 attaques
perpétuées à l'encontre d'Israël ces
derniers jours y compris de tir de
missile antichar et de mortiers ainsi
que des tentatives d'infiltration
terroriste ces initiatives sont menées
sous la tutelle et le soutien de l'Iran
et mett en danger le Liban et ses
habitants merci et si vous voulez
maintenant je suis prêt à recevoir des
questions vous merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur j'ai déjà un certain
nombre de questions mais vous pouvez
évidemment continuer à vous inscrire je
voudrais quand même saluer la présence
parmi nous du président du groupe
d'amitié France Israël Roger carucci qui
désormais fait partie de cette
commission euh donc j'ai plusieurs
demandes de parole et je commence par
mariearlette Carlotti oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur l'Ambassadeur au
nom du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain je tenais à vous exprimer
notre entière solidarité avec le peuple
d'Israël qui a été atrocement attaqué
par le groupe terroriste du Hamas
entraînant des milliers de morts
innocents et mutilant des femmes des
enfants et des bébés aujourd'hui notre
pensée va aussi vers les otages pour
lequel tout doit être entreplé pour leur
libéralisation leur libération
excusez-moi nous partageons avec vous
cette angoisse parce que nous avons
aussi là des ressortissants français les
actions du Hamas que nous condamnons
avec la plus grande fermeté et dont la
seule intention est de détruire Israël
desserve aussi la cause palestinienne en
l'islamisant et en prenant les
populations palestinienne en otage vous
en avez parlé tout à l'heure et c'est
pourquoi il faut que on dise ici que
l'attachement à la cause palestinienne
d'une partie de la communauté
international ne doit pas être confondu
avec la justification des actes
terroristes du Hamas Israël a le droit
de se défendre et quoi que l'on puisse
penser de la politique du premier
ministre monsieur netaniaahou le moment
venu les Israéliens feront
démocratiquement leur propre choix
aujourd'hui l'heure est uniquement à la
solidarité avec Israël deux questions
monsieur ou trois rapidement je reprends
ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure le président
pensez-vous que l'attaque d'Israël par
le Hamas aurait pu aurait dû être prévu
par les services de renseignement pour
nous ça nous paraît impensable
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur ce
point deuxièmement est-ce que je vais
dire quelque chose mais c'est un astre
peut-être mort l'Autorité palestinienne
peut-elle encore jouer un rôle
d'interlocuteur aura-t-elle un rôle à
jouer demain et dans quelles conditions
et puis vous avez déclaré que la France
pouvait avoir une influence dans le
conflit de quel ordre et qu' a pu vous
apporter la présence de la ministre des
Affaires étrangères en
Israël merci beaucoup je propose de
faire des séries de deux questions
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur et puis après
vous permettre de répondre au fil du
donc la question suivante pour Pascal
Alizard merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je fais mi mi les
propos de ma collègue Marie Arlette
Carlotti sur et du président d'ailleurs
sur le soutien et la solidarité que nous
vous exprimons j'ai eu aussi l'occasion
de le faire je vous l'ai dit il y a
quelques instants en tant que
représentant spécial pour les affaires
méditerranéennes à l'OSCE j'aurais en
fait deux questions à à vous poser
question qui se regroupe la première
c'est à votre avis existe-t-il encore un
camp de la paix chez les Palestiniens ça
rejoint un petit peu le propos précédent
ou des personnes avec lesquelles vous
pouvez dialoguer en tant que
représentant spécial j'ai eu l'occasion
de faire travailler ensemble des
parlementaires Israéliens et des membres
du Conseil national palestinien c'était
à Marrakech il y a 3 ans ça semble très
très lointain est-ce que c'est encore
envisageable des pays arabes aussi
s'était récemment rapproché d'Israël bon
il y a un pas en arrière est est-ce que
c'est une posture est-ce que c'est
durable mais peut-on travailler en fait
à réouvrir une discussion et et le
dernier point mais il est en relation
avec le précédent la Chine entretient
avec Israël des relations notamment
économiques mais vient de rappeler son
soutien à la juste cause je cite hein du
du peuple palestinien et pensez-vous que
la Chine va jouer un rôle diplomatique
dans cette crise alors qu'en fait tout
le monde sait qu'elle s'est récemment
rapproché de l'Iran et de l'Arabie
Saoudite je vous remercie Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je vous laisse la parole
oui merci pour vos questions c'est
ouvert oui
euh alors la question de la surprise euh
certes il y avait une surprise est-ce
qu'on a des renseignements préalables
qui ont été mal vu ou mal euh lu ou mal
analysé c'est la grande question que
nous tous israéliens se posent euh et
certes une enquête approfondie va être
faite à ce sujet parce que tous les
Israéliens demandent des réponses et à
comprendre comment est-ce que plus que
1400 citoyens ont été
massacrés mais pour le moment les les
efforts sont pour autour de de l'armée
pour gagner cette cette guerre donc je
n'ai pas de réponse à part reconnaître
le fait qu'il y a eu cert une
défaillance d'ailleurs j'ai vu
aujourd'hui que le chef du renseignement
militaire a même dit qu'il prend sur
lui-même la responsabilité il dit oui
c'est c'est une admissible et j'ai vu
aussi que le le chef des services de
sécurité euh aussi a dit la même chose
donc enfin on est bien conscient qu'il y
a eu des une grande défaillance et qu'il
y a des responsabilités à à é tirer mais
on n'est pas pour le moment au stade de
de voilà de de de de démontrer tout ce
qui s'est passé ou de comprendre tout ce
qui s'est passé mais mais je vous
garantis que
ce
la la vérité va voir lumière voilà c'est
ça parce que nous exisons tous
premièrement nous israéliens de de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et
comment est-ce qu'on a été surpris de de
telle ampleur alors la question du rôle
de l'Autorité palestinienne
euh premièrement il y a un problème il
faut admettre de de légitimité
de de la la direction de de du président
de l'Autorité palestinienne par car
depuis 15 ans plus que 15 ans il y a pas
eu d'élection
présidentiell sous l'autorité
palestinienne
donc si on parle de relancer un
processus politique
euh il il faut un partenaire qui qui
serait vraiment
euh en mesure voilà de prendre des des
engagements et et être suffisamment
courageux pour pour prendre des des des
des des décisions qui seraient historiqu
pour le moment ce que nous voyons c'est
que le l'Autorité palestinienne avec
l'aide internationale qu'elle reçoit
faut bien dire ça elle paye des pensions
ou des allocations
aux familles des des des éoristes qui
sont arrêtés dans les dans les prisons
en Israël ça je trouve très très grave
et maintenant on comprend beaucoup mieux
l'ampleur on a soulevé ça ce problème
déjà à plusieurs reprises mais vous
comprenez bien que si une si un
terroriste sait que s'il est arrêté sa
famille va avir une pension ou une
allocation il sera encore plus motivé de
de de de commettre un acte terroriste
donc il faut voir aussi ça c'estàdire
que l'Autorité palestinienne a un rôle
pour le moment qui encourage la
radicalisation de la population et des
actes
terroriste et ce problème bien sûr a été
soulevé également auprès des autorités
françaises c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau je je je je tiens à à souligner
eu et pour la question du rôle de la
France alors premèrement la France a
exprimé sa solidarité son soutien c'est
très important surtout en ce moment très
difficile cela compte beaucoup pour la
population israélienne car la France est
un un pays proche avec lequel et on a
des des relations dans pratiquement tous
les domaines et mais au-delà de la
solidarité du soutien moral c'est
important que la France aussi continue à
soutenir le droit d'Israël de se
défendre et de de de de répliquer tel
qu'il est nécessaire pour
éradiquer le terrorisme de la bande de
Gaza
je noterai également le rôle de la
France pour vis-à-vis des États de la
région pour éviter un embrasement cela a
été fait et nous apprécions beaucoup
cette intervention et pour la visite de
la ministre Colona en Israël c'était une
visite de solidarité essentiellement
avec le peuple d'Israël c'est important
je suis bon je je suis sûr qu'elle a eu
élaborer la question des otages et et
d'autres sujets euh voilà de d'intérêt
commun
eu alors pour la question des du camp
pour la paix est-ce encore envisageable
monsieur c'est c'est une bonne question
moi j'y crois et parce qu'en fin de
compte c'est ce qu'il faut aboutir il
faut aboutir la paix donc il faut un
camp de paix et je pense
qu'essentiellement non seulement du côté
israélien il a la majorité qui veut la
paix ou peut-être tous les israélien
veulent la paix mais je crois qu'aussi
la majorité des Palestiniens veulent
veulent la paix euh donc c'est un moment
difficile pour tous pour tous tous ceux
qui croient la paix
certes mais comme il était mentionné que
notre h national c'est la ticval
l'espoir et ben on a l'espoir
que que c'est possible
et la Chine est-ce qu'elle a un rôle
diplomatique non pas vraiment la
Chine je crois qu'elle
laisse les États-Unis et les puissances
européennes à à intervenir
diplomatiquement dans la région la
jusqu'aujourd'hui n'a pas joué un rôle
diplomatique même si bon dans la
question de l'Arabie Saoudite et l'Iran
ils étaient un peu l'intermédiaire mais
ça va pas au-delà de cela je crois pas
que la Chine a une volonté prièrement
d'être un acteur c'est ça il n pas de
volonté merci beaucoup donc la parole
François bonau pardon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur notre groupe s'associe aux
propos qui ont été tenus euh par par nos
prédécesseurs euh il est clair qu'
qu'attaquer Israël c'est c'est attaquer
euh tout l'Occident à travers les
valeurs que qui sont défendues
euh la la colonisation a connu une
progression extrêmement importante ces
ces 20 dernières années euh il suffit de
regarder la carte pour s'en convaincre
ou d'aller sur place
euh cette protection des colonies euh
mobilise de de nombreux soldats est-ce
que cette protection n'a pas fragilisé
le système de Défense israélien par
rapport par rapport à la à la bande de
Gaza notamment première question
deuxième question est-ce
que cont
tenu des événements je dirais actuels et
à venir est-ce que certains pays qui ont
signé les accords d'Abraham vont pouvoir
les maintenir où est-ce qu'il y a il y a
un risque de ce
côté-là merci François Jean-Marc
vessousf
pas une demande ah bon alors Michel
gréum merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur tout d'abord
merci pour vos propos préliminaires
c'est un conflit terrible barbare
inhumain qu'il faut condamner avec des
mots forts oui il n'y a aucun doute il
faut que nous soyons tous au côté
d'Israël pour éradiquer définitivement
le Hamas cette organisation islamique
terroriste et mettre hors état de nuire
tous ceux qui la composent mais
parallèlement nous devons trouver une
solution à ce conflit une solution pour
que la paix revienne durablement l'ONU
et l'Union européenne doivent mettre
tout en œuvre pour qu'une solution
pérenne aboutisse et qu'un cess de feu
intervienne
rapidement en effet comme dans tous les
conflit il y a des victimes civiles
collatérales celles et ceux qui n'ont
rien demandé à part vivre une vie
paisible et vous l'avez dit en famille
dans la paix et fraternité que ce soit
au sein du peuple
israélien que palestinien rappelons
qu'il est nécessaire de respecter la 4e
Convention de Genève relative à la
protection des personnes civiles en
temps de guerre de plus il y a nécessité
de faire libérer les les otages du Hamas
le plus rapidement possible pour leur
sécurité ce samedi la rapporteur
spéciale des Nations Unies franccesca
albanis a alerté l'ONU sur un risque de
nettoyage ethnique à Gaza les Nations
Unies quant à eux parlent d'une
catastrophe humanitaire inédite Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur mon groupe politique à
plusieurs reprises s'est positionné sur
une solution à deux états quelle est la
police la position d'Israël à ce sujet à
votre avis quel frin peut-on lever pour
aboutir à une solution de paix pérenne
et aboutir à ce que ces deux peuples
puissent coexister et enfin quelles
mesures sont prises aujourd'hui par
Israël pour éviter de nouvelles victimes
civiles et pour la libération des otage
merci merci Michel Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur
oui
alors sur la question
des de la répartition des forces de
l'armée entre la S jourdanie et la bande
de Gaza c'est une des questions que
l'enquête qui va être lancée sur surt le
fond de cette surprise don on a parlé
évoqué avant va devoir regarder c'est
est-ce que effectivement il y avait
suffisantment de de force le long de la
bande de Gaza surtout s'il y avait déjà
des renseignements de de d'une possible
attaque
euh donc je je n'ai pas la réponse mais
je suis sûr que c'est une des question
une des question qui va être examiné
pendant cette enquête sur la question
des accords d'Abraham alors
euh je suis convaincu que les intérêts
des des partenaires de des accords
d'Abraham sont sont fort et ils ont
l'intérêt de de les maintenir notamment
également l'Arabie Saoudite qui était en
cours de de de normalisation des
relations avec Israël bon pour le moment
évidemment c'est c'est c'est gelé si on
peut dire mais je pense que c'est une
mesure temporaire et car les comme je
dis bien les intérêts de de ces pays
d'avoir une stabilité dans la région et
de prospérité économique et également
confrontter la la menace iranienne sont
beaucoup plus forts que
euh que voilà que de ce qui se passe
avec le Hamas d'ailleurs aucun de ces
pays-là ouvertement dira qu'il qu'il
qu'il soutient le Hamas tous comprennent
très bien que ce que justement c'est le
le danger qui que présente le Hamas
comme organisation terroriste qui qui
qui est présente également à leur propre
dans leur propre pays
donc pour le moment c'est c'est c'est
c'est gelé mais c'est mais mais c'est
voilà je crois que ça va relancer
prochainement alors la question sur
enfin c'était une question plusieur
question vous avez soulever
oui bien évidemment je suis tout à fait
d'accord nous sommes d'accord qu' en à
la fin du conflit il fautir une solution
politique la solution des deux états est
certainement une solution qui est sur la
table il y a peut-être d'autres
mais il faudra bien sûr aboutir à une
solution politique du conflit ça je on
est tout à fait engagé avec le Hamas
bien sûr il est hors de question parce
que il est il il ne reconnaît ni
l'existence de l'État d' Israël ni le
veut la paix avec Israël et donc il a il
y a aucune négociation qui peut être
possible avec lui mais avec l'Autorité
palestinienne on espère pouvoir oui
relancer un processus
politique merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
Guillaume Gontard
oui merci merci Monsieur Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur à mon tour et comme j'ai
pu l'exprimer en en séance publique
mercredi dernier je tiens au nom du
groupe écologiste que je que je préside
à vous témoigner toute notre solidarité
face à l'épreuve sans précédent qui
afflige Israël et son peuple toutes nos
pensées évidemment aux victimes et au
aux otages nous sommes profondément
attachés à la sécurité d'Israël et du
peuple juif estbranlé le 7 octobre par
les attaques terroristes abominables
conduites par le Hamas et rien ne peut
et ne pourra justifier ces attaques
abominable pour garantir cette sécurité
votre gouvernement a choisi une forme de
réponse extrêmement forte qui a déjà
fait plusieurs milliers de victimes et
qui devrait conduire prochainement une
opération militaire terrestre dans la
bande de de Gaza face à ces attaques
terroristes du Hamas sans précédent le
droit à la défense et à votre sécurité
est évidemment incontestable cependant
nous nous inquiétons d'une réponse qui
ne permettrait pas de respecter le le
droit international tout d'abord parce
que des milliers de vies sont en jeu des
vies de civiles Palestiniens femmes
enfants vieillards par milliers des vies
de soldats israéliens et de réservistes
dans des proportions qui dépendront de
l'ampleur de vos objectifs de vos
objectifs militaires que vous ne pouvez
pas nous détailler ici et évidemment
nous le comprenons bien ce choix nous
interroge aussi car nous portons la
conviction profonde qu'une nouvelle
guerre contre la terreur ne résoudra
hélas rien l'histoire des dernières
décennies nous a montré que les
démocraties et les armées régulières ne
peuvent pas gagner ces guerres pas même
la plus grande armée du monde depuis la
prise du pouvoir du Hamas à Gaza les
opérations militaires dans la bande de
Gaza interviennent régulièrement plom
Durc en 2008 pilier de défense en 2012
bordure protectrice en 2014 et désormais
glave de fer et hélas ne change pas
grand-chosees tel ladre dont les têtes
repoussent si le Hamas est
temporairement affaibli il en ressort à
terme nourri par la haine et renforcé et
pour encore quels futurs horaires la
réponse n'est évidemment pas simple et
certainement politique comment retrouver
le chemin de l'espoir vous l'avez un
petit peu esquissé donc j'avais quelques
questions est-il possible de combattre
le Hamas à Gaza sans imposer une
punition collective insoutenable au
peuple palestinien et quelle précaution
prend votre état-major pour épagner des
civil qui ne peuvent pas quitter la
bande de
Gaza nous considérons également que que
seule une solution politique à deux ét
garantir la sécurité d'Israël le
gouvernant que que vous représentez
partage-t-il cette ominion vous l'avez
un petit peu
exprimé quelles sont également les les
conditions selon vous pour espérer le
feu et notamment avec
quel interlocuteur pardon vous en avez
un peu parlé israël peut-il construire
la paix et comment selon vous contrer le
Hamas durablement vous l'avez dit une
majorité veut la paix et donc l'espoir
est certainement là
merci merci Guillaume Nicole
Duranton merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur donc mon groupe
RDPI s'associe effectivement et condamne
fermement donc les attaques du Hamas
envers Israël et vous apporte toute
notre solidarité donc l'attaque sans
précédent du Hamas risque de saper les
tentatives de normalisation entre Israël
et l'Arabie Saoudite poids lourd du
Moyen-Orient ces négociations en cours
parinées par les États-Unis pourrait
voir l'Arabie Saoudite reconnaît Israël
en échange de garantie de sécurité
américaine donc le 20 septembre le
prince héritier saoudien Mohamed Ben
salam a fait état de progrès avec le
rapprochement avec Israël mais a exiger
des avancées sur la question
palestinienne considérant considéré
pardon comme une priorité par son père
en ce sens le timing de l'attaque du
Hamas n'est pas un Odin selon certains
spécialistes donc qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui de la négociation
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
merci
alors pour la première question je
voudrais souligner comme j'ai déjà
mentionné que Israël se soumet au droit
international et comme j'ai donné comme
exemple quand on envoie des tractes pour
avertir la population contre des des des
attaque ce n'est pas requis par le droit
international c'est une initiative
quiisraël a inventé ce ce n'a pas été
fait par les forces allié quand ils ont
attaqué Baghdad et Moussou durant la
guerre du Golf n'a pas été fait dans
d'autres régions du monde c'est une
invention israélienne qui qui démonte
monre à quel point nous nous nous
vraiment nous sommes sensibles pour
éviter les pertes
civiles la petite différence oui
ok non c'est bien alors les
opérations ne règlent rien vous avez dit
je crois que c'est aussi la leçon que
nous avons tiré c'est pour ça qu'après
16 ans on veut changer le mode operandi
du traitement de ces attaques
terroristes qui ser CELI parce que si
dans le passé on pass on pensait que bon
on va taper fort on va éliminer les
certains dirigeants et après ça va se
calmer en espérant que le Hamas
peut-être souhaite changer son attitude
et devenir un acteur politique on était
un peu sous cette dillusion
euh on voit que ce n'est pas le cas
hein et donc c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je dis bien le paradigme
a changé c'estàd on va on peut pas se
permettre que de nouveau les les les
commoditaires de ces attaques
meurtrières vont rester en impunité car
on sait très bien que du moment que il y
aura un cesser le feu ils vont tout de
suite se remettre à à préparer la
prochaine attaque n'oublions pas qu'en
même temps il y a toujours des missiles
des roquites qui sont tirés du
territoire de de la bande de Gaza sur
Israël donc ça aussi il faut il faut il
faut traiter parce qu'on peut
pas accepter que cela continue à
terroriser notre population donc la la
donne sera cette fois-ci différente et
bien sûr la la solution militaire c'est
pas la solution de tous les problèmes
mais c'est la la condition préalable
pour avoir une solution politique voilà
euh alors est-ce que quelles sont les
conditions pour respérer le CESS le feu
le CESS le feu n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour premièrement et puis si vous voulez
une situation idéale raisonnable et
juste c'est que le Hamas dit ok on
relâche les otages nous sortons de nos
de nos caches avec les mains avec les
bras en l'air il y aura le CESS et le
feu et dans ce cas-là on peut on peut
imaginer une autre une autre issue du
conflit mais je crois pas que c'est à
l'ordre du jour donc malheureusement ce
n'est on n'est pas dans cette direction
là alors pour l'Arabie Saoudite euh oui
on était très proche
d'un d'un accord d' normalisation et
comme je je peux partager cette analyse
qui dit que le timing de cette attaque
de Hamas n'était pas
euh n'était pas par hasard choisi pour
ce moment-là
donc ça va retarder ce qui devait se
faire je crois pas que ça va empêcher
dans le futur un un rapprochement et une
normalisation de entre israë et la parce
que les intérêts sont sont beaucoup plus
forts
merci merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
Giselle
Jourda monsieur le
Président je souhaitais Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur avoir donc votre
éclairage dans cette situation
dramatique et connaître la nature des
relations donc avec la Russie ce qui me
paraît parfaitement important et je
souhaitais savoir quel témoignage vous
avez donc reçu en en octobre dernier aux
alentours du 7 donc de ce pays puisqu'on
peut au niveau de la Russie se dire que
cette situation dramatique peut
permettre à la Russie de se dédoiner
quelque part par rapport à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sur notre sol européen
avec l'Ukraine je avoir votre éclairage
là-dessus merci
beaucoup merci GIS Valérie
Boyet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur à mon tour de
vous dire toute notre solidarité notre
compassion pour les programmes
abominables que vous avez vécu et je
crois qu' ont saisi des
froids le monde entier en tout cas une
partie du monde dont fait partie la
France euh je ne peux pas ne pas penser
à nos compatriotes français qui sont
nombreux et au désarrois dans
lequel cette guerre abominable cette
déclaration de guerre abominable et ses
conséquences sur le territoire d'Israël
même nous plonge en tant que Français en
tant qu'amis Israël et en tant que
personne qui avons énormément d'amis
Juifs parce que c'est de ça aussi dont
il s'agit on prendre leur nouvelles dès
qu'on peut on tremble à chaque fois
qu'on allume la télévision et on est
plongé dans l'horreur pour quelque chose
à laquelle je crois que personne
n'aurait imaginé une horreur pareille
euh Israël vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure Monsieur l'Ambassadeur euh a
inventé quelque chose de totalement
inédit c'est-à-dire de prévenir les
population civile euh qu'elles doivent
être évacuées puisque jamais au grand
jamais
vous ne vous en prenez au
civil cependant forcé de constater que
aujourd'hui ces populations n'ont nulle
part où aller puisque soit elles sont
retenues par le ramas soit les pays à
côté n'en veulent pas en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on nous
relate et on sait très bien que même si
vous êtes en facee de guerre même si le
monde est derrière derè vous pour pour
pour cette guerre en tout cas le
nôtre c'est aussi la paix à laquelle
nous pensant tous et c'est à l'après et
que cet après va dépendre en partie de
la façon devant laquelle se le ramas
utilisera ou non sa propre population
comme bouclier humain comme otage avec
les otages Israéliens et les otages
internationaux aussi qu'il détiennent
donc ma question est la suivante
savez-vous pouvez-vous nous nous en dire
plus sur les pays qui serait susceptible
de de prendre ses
populations et quel rôle les Américains
précisément vont-ils jouer ou en tout
cas ont-ils
euh son sont-ils intervenus pour ces
populations euh pour le les les les
jours qui
viennent voilà je vous remercie merci
Valérie Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
voudrais me permettre de compléter un
peu la la question de Giselle
Jourda Radio J hier annonçait que le
président Zelenski avait demandé à faire
une visite en Israël que vra simpblement
il lui aurait été répondu que ce n'était
pas le bon moment euh est-ce que les
événement de la semaine dernière ont
changé quelque chose dans la position
d'Israël vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine comp
tenu du positionnement de la la Russie
par rapport à l'Iran et par rapport à
des ventes d'armes de l'Iran à la
Russie est-ce que cette situation a
évolué sur la la prudence qui avait été
en tout cas celle d'Israël vis-à-vis du
conflit ukrainien merci beaucoup je vous
laisse répondre aux autres
questions merci
euh alors j'admets que je ne suis pas
expert dans les relations avec la Russie
c'est pas tellement ma compétence
et cependant
euh et aussi à votre question nous avons
des relations particulières avec la
Russie parce que c'est pas qu'on a une
une frontière géographique avec la
Russie mais nous avons quand même une
présence militaire pas loin de notre
frontière
syranienne la Syrie oui syranien on dit
syrienne pardon
syrienne ce qui fait
que nous devons tenir compte de cette
présence en
Syrie il contrôle
le ciel l'espace aérien de la Syrie et
donc c'est important d'être en
coordination reprochée étroite voilàve
avec eux ce qui fait qu'aussi dans le
contexte du du conflit et de la guerre
en Ukraine notre position est plus
disons
nuancée même si au niveau des valeurs je
crois que c'est clair de de quel côté
nous nous positionnons
euh alors cela à voir également avec la
proposition de la visite du du président
Zelenski
euh je pense pas que c'est le moment euh
idéal disons pour mener une telle
visite mais bien sûr il sera je pense
qu'il sera venu dans des temps dans un
temps normal voilà quand les conditions
le
permettront
eu alors pour la question oui de de
l'évacuation des de la population des
Gaza je ne sais pas s'il y a des pays
qui sont qui ser prêt à prendre cette
population j'ai vu un propos de l'union
de la prés de l'Union européne qu chose
ce sujet nce
pas
ok
ouais en général et il y a je suis pas
sûr que ça fonctionne ça marche ou pas
ça marche et il y a en coordination et
quotidien entre T et les représentants
deorganisation internationale et et et
c'est depuis des années c'est pas quelqu
chose à nouveau
et cette coordination mérite que il y a
des des abris pour la population et
palestinien au sou de Gaza c'est pour
c'est pour laquelle qu'on a demandé que
la population de ville de Gaza et son
ban lieu et seront évacué et et au sou
de la bande pour que
ils avoir les les abris et préparer déjà
pour eux et autour ranonis
et on sait que Miss goutierch et le
secrétaire général de l'ONU a mentionné
que ce n'est
pas en bon solution mais de quelle
solution il s'agit de laisser les
population être bouclier humain ça ça
c'est une solution ça c'est la
proportionnalité demandée
alors je trouve que au milieu de
situation très difficiles on fait tout
ce qu'il faut et et nécessaire ser et
vis-à-vis une ennemie meurtrière et
population qui est pris a Tage par cette
organisation
terroriste et j'ajouterai qu'on n pas
demandé la population de la ville de
Gaza de quitter la bande de Gaza mais
simplement de se déplacer 20 km hein
c'est comme parisvailles donc c'est pas
si compliqué que ça euh et cela
suffirait voilà donc il s'agit pas de
les expulser dans un autre pays ou de
les faire transférer dans autre pays
simplement voilà 20 dégager 20 km pour
pour pour pas être pour éviter les
pertes civiles
voilà Roger carucci
oui Monsieur l'Ambassadeur d'abord un
élément quand même si les Israéliens
demandent au gaz oui d'aller vers le sud
de la bande de Gaza c'est parce qu'en
réalité tous les
tunnels organisés par le ramas sont sur
Gaza City et pas vers le sud parce que
par définition ça n'intéressait pas le
ramas de faire des tunnels vers l'Égypte
donc forcément c'est la zone des tunnels
qui est la zone la plus menacée par un
conflit direct et c'est donc de cette
zone là que les israélien demandent le
départ de la population moi je voudrais
insister Monsieur l'Ambassadeur sur
qu'est-ce que on peut faire dans les
conditions actuelles
pour sauver ce qui peut l'être des
accords
d'Abraham il est clair j'ai organisé ici
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de réunions
auquel participai des représentants
marocains émiratis
Bahraini
bon un
élément quand même à noter c'est que
pour le moment je dis bien pour le
moment et malgré les manifestations on
le sait bien de la rue arabe très
sensible à la cause palestinienne pour
le moment je n'ai vu aucun gouvernement
pas plus marocain que
bahinimirati par exemple annuler les
accord passé aucun et j'ai bien noté que
le prince Mohamed Ben Salman ne dit pas
qu'il annulle le processus il dit on le
suspend ce qui voudrait laisser entendre
que
euh si les choses venaient enfin à
s'apaiser euh le processus pourrait
reprendre qu'est-ce que fait en en en
pratique si je peux me permettre de
poser la question et si vous pouvez
répondre Israël par rapport à tous ces
états arabes avec qui il avait très
nettement depuis 34 ans amélioré ses
relations qui évidemment sont soumis euh
à euh des médias ou à une population
très sensible quand même à la cause
palestinienne et qui ne rentrre
peut-être pas dans le détail d'un
certain nombre d'éléments et qui bon
peuvent faire pression sur le
gouvernement qu'est-ce qu'Israël peut
faire pour sauver les accords d'Abraham
parce que je suis certain qu'après la
phase actuel le la sauvegarde des
accords d'Abraham change la donne et
l'image d'Israël à la fois avec le monde
arabe et avec le monde occidental euh il
y a il y a vraiment quelque chose
d'essentiel à sauvegarder là est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ce que le le
gouvernement israélien fait ou peut
faire en la
matière merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
vous peut-être bruno Sido et puis après
je vous laisserai
répondre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous nous avez
dit tout à l'heure que le Hamas
continuait à bombarder
Israël je voudrais vous poser une
première question c'est comment le ass
fait-il pour amasser autant d'armes sur
cette bande de Gaza alors même qu'on n
dit que vous avez dépensé beaucoup
d'argent pour l'encercler ou alors
est-ce que c'est la marine israélienne
qui ne fait pas son travail c'est ma
première question la deuxième elle est
très simple vous allez attaquer la bande
de Gaza c'est ça semble clair vous
connaissez le les dégâts que peuvent
faire la communication les images et
cetera comment peut-on faire pour
arrêter cette communication de guerre
sur le champ de bataille euh après tout
il y a les pilones de téléphonie mobile
qu'on peut bloquer il y a également les
satellites on peut leur les demander
leur demander au propriétaires de les
arrêter ça a déjà été fait donc
envisagez-vous de faire quelque chose
pour qu'il y ait pas de communication
pendant les opérations merci merci
Monsieur assadeur à vous la parole merci
euh alors comment savez les accords
d'Abraham alors je crois que plus que je
crois je sais que quand même
les les canaux de communication sont
sont ouverts nous avons toujours des
ambassades dans dans dans dans tous ces
dans C dans les quatre pays des accords
d'Abraham et je crois qu'aussi les
États-Unis font pression sur ces sur les
pays des accords d'Abraham également sur
l'Arabie Saoudite de voilà de de
maintenir même si c'est en en cachette
ou en de manière plus plus discrète les
les les relations et surtout ne pas
ne pas
suspendre aussi c'est une suspension
c'estpension temporaire donc il y a des
contacts mais bien sûr qui se font tout
en discrétion et le rôle des États-Unis
à ce sujet est
important c'est ça c'est donc j'insiste
que même s'il y a une
tension
momentané sur le long
terme comme je dis bien les intérêts des
des des de ces pays-là sont beaucoup
plus forts de de continuer le le
rapochement avec Israël justement pour
changer la donne dans dans dans le
proche
orient comment le Hamas a réussi à
masser tant de missile alors c'est une
bonne question vous savez c'est c'est
c'est pas si compliqué que ça en fin de
compte et justement on avait vu cette
vidéo qui a circulé je pense la semaine
dernière qu'on que on peut transformer
des tuyaux pour d'irrigation ou des de
enfin pour pour canaliser de l'eau
est les transformer en missiles ce sont
pas des missiles super sophistiqués
téléguidé et cetera
heureusement donc vous prenez un tuyau
en acier suffisamment fort vous Remes de
l'explosif et enfin je connais pas t les
détails mais ce que je veux dire que
c'est ça peut être assez facilement
dissimulé sous d'autres sous
d'autres apparence c'est pas que c'est
c'est pas que voilà il y a des Miss un
missile complet et et passer voilà sous
nos yeux sans qu'on sans qu'on
s'aperçoit mais c'est différents tous
les éléments qui qui fait que après on
peut construire dans dans dans des dans
des ateliers assez primitifs en fin de
compte faire monter ses ces moyens de
destruction
oui et comme vous avez vu dans cette
vidéo apparemment c'est ces tuyaux de C
tu d'au on été financé par l'aide
européenne
d'ailleurs
euh communation à propos la question de
bloquer les communication
et si on a les moyens je ne peux pas
dire mais si c'est ça sera possible
c'est un autre question de la démocratie
est-ce que la démocratie peut et bloquer
les communications et
et et changer
et à cause de ça changer l'équilibrium
de de de la guerre et à propos qu'on est
un état démocrate démocratique et ça ça
pose une question est-ce que on peut le
est-ce que on voulons le faire on va
dire comme ça est-ce que nous voulions
le faire
et je dis rien à propos la
capabilité
merci alors pour terminer donc j'ai une
demande de parole de Jean-Baptiste Le
Moine merci beaucoup Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je m'assoucie pleinement
au propos de de Nicole Duranton sur la
solidarité exprimée par le le groupe
RDPI à la suite de de cette attaque
terroriste ignoble et nous sommes là
dans le temps court qui est celui des
conséquence de l'attaque
et de des opérations qui sont menées euh
euh pour y répondre néanmoins nous ne
devons pas oublier le le moyen terme et
le long terme puisque vous l'avez dit
vous-même
euh à la fin du conflit il faut une
situation politique euh néanmoins
j'entends dans vos propos que il y
a la solution à deux États mais vous
l'avez dit vous-même il y en a peut-être
d'autres euh et donc ça m'interroge sur
la volonté euh corelétat Israël ou non
de mettre fin
euh justement à une politique qui
peut-être euh encourage
euh un certain nombre de de colonies à
se développer or les Nations Unies ont
bien précisé que c'était aussi un
obstacle majeur à l'instauration de la
paix durable et c'est cette paix durable
qu'on doit viser et
donc je sais que la commission des
affaires étrangères s'était rendue je
crois l'année dernière en déplacement
euh qu'elle avait pu constater sur le
terrain euh effectivement les effets euh
de ce type d'action euh et donc on voit
bien qu'à un moment quand on veut sortir
d'un conflit par le haut euh il faut que
tout le monde y mette du sien euh et de
ce point de vue-là euh qu'est prêt à
faire euh l'État d'Israël pour faciliter
euh et bien euh la mise en œuvre de euh
la solution à deux États qui est dans la
communauté internationale quand même euh
largement
agréé merci Jean-Baptiste pour terminer
la parole est au président
Cambon merci président effectivement
comme le rappelait Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
l'année dernière une délégation de la de
la Commission s'est rendue et j'en
faisait partie en Israël et a eu
l'occasion d'aller sur la bande de Gaza
je pense du reste que nous serons une
des dernières délégation parlementaires
à nous rendre à Gaza d'ici
longtemps ce que nous avons constaté
c'est qu'effectivement la situation
était assez dramatique mais ça tout le
monde le sait en revanche je souhaite
vous interroger sur l'aide au
développement que l'Europe et et la
France particulièrement apporte au
territoire Palestiniens et deun manière
générale à Gaza les derniers chiffres
vous les avez vu dans la
presse plus de près d'un un peu moins
d'un milliard de de dollars ont été
dépensés la France depuis 1999 je le dis
sous le contrôle du xori qui a été
rapporteur de ce budget pendant des
années c'est c'est 500 millions depuis
1999 je dois dire que sur place nous
avons eu beaucoup de mal à nous rendre
compte de ce que le Hamas puisque c'est
lui qui est au commande à Gaza faisait
de cet argent car si je mets de côté le
ce qui était je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
est maintenant le magnifique centre
culturel français qui était juste en
face du siège du Hamas je pense pas je
pense qu'il a dû subir de beaucoup de
dommag et l'usine des EAU que la France
à financer nous n'avons pas eu
l'occasion véritable de
constater la bonne utilisation de ces
crédits je mets de côté l'action de
l'unra que nous avons reçu ici en
commission et qui au niveau notamment de
l'éducation et des écoles faisait
certainement un très gros effort mais
comme notre commission a à examiner le
budget de l'aide au développement que
des questionnements très importants
interviennent au niveau européen y
compris à Bruxelles dans un certain
nombre de pays sur l'utilisation que la
Palestine de manière générale et Gaza
plus particulièrement fait de cet argent
quel est le sentiment de votre
gouvernement sur cette aide euh est-ce
quelle quelle attitude un pays comme la
France doit avoir à la fois pour ne pas
oublier l'intérêt des populations
civiles mais ne pas donner des moyens
euh à à ces à ces gens de détourner une
partie de cette aide vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure au début de vos propos le
fait que euh le
au niveau de ramala on finançait les
familles des terroristes bien évidemment
tout ceci pose des questions à nos
concitoyens qui se demande si
véritablement l'aide de l'Europe ne sert
pas à favoriser et à développer le
terrorisme quel est le sentiment de
votre gouvernement monsieur
ambassade
merci alors on dit souvent que les
colonies c'est l'obstacle à la solution
des deux États mais je voudrais rappeler
que avec l'Égypte ça n'a pas empêché
acccord de paix Israël s'est retiré de
tout le Sinaï et a évacué les colonies
qui étaient sur place également euh
Israël s'est retiré de
l'entière territoire de l'entier
territoire de de de la bande de Gaza où
il y avait également des des des
colonies
et c'est justement en pensant que ça
sera en pensant que voilà que si si les
colonist c'est un obstacle à la paix
alors maintenant qu'on qu'on qu'on les
retire de la bande de Gaza on a pour
avoir la paix et vivre en bon voisinage
or ce qu'on ce qu'on a encontré c'est
juste le contraire donc euh la question
des colonies elle devra être résoute
dans le cadre des du processus de paix
qui aura lieu plus tard et Israël comme
je dis bien a déjà prouvé que le cas
échéant en échange d'une véritable paix
durable pourra éventuellement évacuer
des des
colonies euh pour l'aide au
développement de l'Union européenne et
de la France euh effectivement si vous
remarquerez qu'en fait l'Autorité
palestinienne reçoivent la plus haute
aide euh en du monde si on traduit ça en
père capita donc vous demandez pu et
cela depuis 50 ans alors moi je
m'attendrais dans ces conditions là que
le l'autorité palestinen deviennent
comme le Singapour comme Hong Kong c'est
c'est vraiment et et et on voit que
c'est pas le cas alors et je crois que
cela démontre sans être un grand expert
en comptabilité qu'il y a un problème
sur la gestion de de cet argent et un
manque de transparence premièrement au
sein de l'Autorité palestinienne il y a
jamais des discussions dans leur propre
Parlement qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cet
argent est-ce que c'est destiné pour les
pour les besoins de de notre population
et cetera mais ce qui est plus important
c'est c'est voilà votre devoir vis-à-vis
des contribuables qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de cet argent est-ce qu'il est est-ce
qui sert vraiment la cause pour laquelle
on veut
donc notre position c'est pas de de de
de d'arrêter mais mais c'est c'est de
renforcer le le le contrôle pour qu'il
soit un contrôle efficace et que avoir
l'assurance que voilà que chaque euro
qui qui qui est destiné pour pour l'ut
pistienne va la cause pour laquelle il
il doit être destiné merci c'est aussi
c'est aussi pertinent de de demander
c'est qui va dépenser sur le terrain
est-ce que c'est une gouvernement un on
c'est qui sont les person qui qui fit
cette ONG est-ce qu'ils
ont le
le le bien vie de de la population
palestinienne et cetera et cetera c'est
pas toujours les cas à propos unra on on
sait qu'il y a un manifestation de la
haine dans le dans le livre des études
que HRA et imprime depuis des années
c'est pas quelque chose chose de nouveau
on a exprimé de ça vis-à-vis tout les
gouvernement européen tout le
gouvernement occidental et d'aujourd'hui
rien n'était fait alors
c'est voir toute la chaîne de de
dépenses on va dire comme ça qui est pas
corrompu et j'ajouterai aussi qu' un
autre problème qui est qui est lié à
l'aide au développement mais des
associations c'estàd des des ONG et non
gouvernemental parce que vous en fait
vous faites référence à
l'argent l'aide officielle mais il y a
aussi toutes les récoltes d'argent qui
se font dans des euh dans des mosquées
dans et au sein de la population
musulmane en Europe pour des
associations dites caritatives euh dans
la bande de Gaza et on sait très bien
que ce n'est qu'une couverture pour euh
détourner de l'argent vers le Hamas et
les moyens existent c'est pas qu'il y a
besoin d'avancer des nouvelles lois de
nouvelles régulations il y a les la
réglementation pour lutter contre le le
branchissement d'argent et la le
financement
des des des des organisations
terroristes sauf que dans le dans le cas
précis de des organisations dans la
bande de Gaza ce n'est pas efficacement
appliqué alors donc ça aussi c'est un
autre aspect qui qui qu'il faut traiter
au-delà de l'aide
officielle monsieur le Président je vous
remercie
pour m'inviter et je suis à votre
disposition éventuellement pour futur
audition Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci
beaucoup pour vos propos je voudrais
dire en en conclusion que vous pouvez
voir qu'ici malgré une représentation
j'allais dire éclectique des différentes
compositions qui politiqu qui qui sont
au Sénat il y a en tout cas il n'y a pas
de voix dissonnante et nous appelons les
choses par leur nom et je voudrais
saluer évidemment cette ces prises de
position même si chacun a sa position et
son son point de vue sur les choses don
tel qu'elles doivent se dérouler
désormais et tel qu'elles devront se
dérouler en tout cas il y a trois
messages importants qui je pense sont
passés aujourd'hui c'est qu'ilabord un
message d'amitié un message de soutien
et puis également un message d'espoir et
ce message d'espoir il est autour de la
paix que nous espérons tous et au sour
de solution auquel chacun et chacune ici
espère
pouvoir qui espère voir aboutir et puis
parfois peut-être espère participer
également voilà donc en tout cas vous
pouvez compter sur nous et puis je suis
très heureux que vous ayez pu que vous
ayez accepté de venir rapidement nous
rencontrer et puis je j'espère qu'il y
aura évidemment d'autres occasions
prochaines plus heureuses de pouvoir se
retrouver dans cette commission merci
beaucoup Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci
beaucoup à vous tous
merci